lady gaga is head over heels for her
boyfriend michael polanski
you know i think it's always wonderful
to shout love from the rooftop
a source tells e.t that the singer and
the entrepreneur are the real deal
saying quote michael is her north star
he is such a grounding and guiding
presence for her
and just one person believes in you and
it can change everything
after a tough year riddled by a busy
work schedule the pandemic
and the horrifying attack of her friend
and dog napping
the source says michael has been her
rock through it all
the couple has a deep connection and he
sees a side of her
a lot of people don't the real stephanie
who's vulnerable
and complex quote he loves lady gaga
but he's in love with stephanie it could
just make me cry
and get this he's not in it for the fame
the source adds that he is very happy
being out of the spotlight
and letting his girlfriend shine it just
means the world to me
the pair has been making an effort to
avoid being photographed and they want
to keep their life
as private as possible but the source
assured
that doesn't mean he isn't around it
just makes my heart sing
gaga is also feeling like herself again
she's back in new york city
and feeling completely recharged
according to the source
she's happy inspired and feeling very
creative
live your life the source says at the
end of the day she's a family person
she's at peace when she's surrounded by
people she loves and who love her
i get a kick out of you
the singer is currently in nyc
performing at radio city music hall
alongside tony bennett for his last set
of shows at the iconic venue
on tuesday the duo released their new
single and announced their follow-up to
2014's
cheek to cheek love for sale
but back to her love life the
oscar-winning actress went instagram
official with michael last year
after sharing a photo of the pair loved
up while on a yacht in miami
in march a source told dt that gaga is
super in love with michael
she has been telling her friends that
she wants to get through a few projects
and then focus on settling down gaga
wants to have children one day
and sees a future with michael